all right so the big media story over
the last 48 hours was Wednesday night's
CNN Town Hall of the failed former
president Donald Trump on yesterday's
show we did an extensive review of what
was said the audience's role and
reactions laughing and cheering at the
most depraved anti-democratic and
dishonest moments anchor Caitlin
Collins's respectable attempt to do some
fact checking up against the unfortunate
reality that Trump mostly steamrolled
right over her had the crowd on his side
for the lies and that the environment in
some total didn't really conform to one
where serious fact-checking and pinning
Trump down could happen in part because
of the crowd and because of the format
and so many other things so we then
heard again on yesterday's show from
people in the media
uh Joe Scarborough and others members of
the House and Senate we heard from all
sorts of different people about the town
hall and we heard from voters as well
and in a focus group that CNN did of
trump supporters they were not more
impressed or less impressed by Trump
based on the town hall it did nothing
one way or the other to influence their
opinion of trump and then the question
becomes well what about independent
voters what about Democrats what about
non-trump Republicans and it's hard to
imagine that they were overly thrilled
by what took place so now there's a
media question
what happens with CNN after this insane
Town Hall we know that based on the new
relatively new leadership of CNN by
Chris Licht that there is a change of
Direction happening that's already
happened the network has hired a number
of Republic former Republican officials
and so on to to be on the network but
Chris Licht did tell Kara Swisher during
an interview back in November that CNN
is not going to become the Trump News
Network this was the current head of CNN
Chris Licht speaking with Kara Swisher
you ended up talking about him for eight
hours a day and we're not going to do
that we're going to be very
um clear and take everything on a
case-by-case basis about what level of
coverage it should be so meaning that it
will not be quite hands we are not going
to be a 24 7 Trump News Network okay
um is that what they are sticking to or
is it not and to be clear
Trump is a former president
in the completely unprecedented
situation where he is under criminal
indictment was recently found liable
civilly for sexual assault and
defamation tried to hang on to power
despite having lost on and on and on all
these different things so it makes sense
that corporate media talks about the guy
it makes sense but the question is what
is the sort of tone and tenor of that
coverage is it sycophantic is it uh uh
what what exactly is it going to be now
just as interestingly in the 48 hours
since the Trump Town Hall
during which Chris Licht defended what
CNN did there has been some I guess we
could call it light Rebellion coming
from within uh within CNN there's an
interesting article on uh semaphore
America was served very well by what we
did last night CNN chairman defends Town
Hall but
um there are others who are quoted here
the view from CNN staff is that it may
not be particularly the best thing and
they point out that they don't love the
fact that the audience was filled with
Trump supporters CNN senior media
reporter Oliver Darcy wrote It's hard to
see how America was served by the
spectacle of lies that aired on CNN
Wednesday evening
um and Licht said I absolutely
unequivocally believe America was served
well so there's a couple different
questions here question one is what
actually happens on CNN as far as Trump
coverage goes does it become friendlier
than maybe what we saw in 2016 in 2020 I
don't know that's certainly one question
the other aspect to this is what about
disaffected Fox News viewers because
that's part of the timing of this entire
thing Trump has increasingly turned
against Fox News over the last year now
with the firing of Tucker Carlson there
is a significant contingent of Maga
people who they may be watching Fox News
Now reluctantly or they may have
abandoned Fox News and they want a new
home does Chris Licht want to appeal to
those people
and does he want to try to make the new
home for those folks CNN and can he do
that in any way that is even remotely
responsible as far as journalism is
concerned or can you really only appeal
to those people by becoming overtly
sycophantic and brown-nosing about
Donald Trump a lot of questions in this
segment not a ton of answers we simply
have to wait and see but it's not
looking particularly inspiring I think
that's where we can leave it for today
sometimes it can be tough to maintain an
emotional connection with your
significant other you might work in
different places at different times
there might be a kid in the way it can
be hard to find time for date nights
especially because kids demand so much
attention which is why I love our
sponsor paired which is the app for
couples the app will prompt you with a
daily question or a game or a guided
conversation all designed by Leading
psychologists and the point is to just
have a deeper connection with your
partner boost intimacy build a deeper
knowledge of one another my girlfriend
and I will use the prompts on paired
throughout the day to stay connected for
instance we answered a prompt about what
we remember most from the early days of
the relationship it really helps us
learn new things and there can be funny
moments as well an independent study
found that couples using paired saw 36
percent increase in the quality of their
relationship and giving a paired
subscription as a gift is also a really
great idea you can try it free for seven
days and get 25 off a subscription go to
paired.com Pacman the link is in the
description